IAN FETTE: Alright.
Thank you everyone
so much for coming.
Welcome to Google I/O 2010.
It's a real honor to be here at
the last session of the day.
I hope you guys did
enjoyed yourselves.
So you guys enjoyed
the session so far?
[APPLAUSE].
Alright.
So, on the day one keynote, the
opening of Google I/O 2010, we
showed you where the
HTML5 platform was.
We showed you a bunch of great
capabilities that we were
adding to the platform.
We showed you some awesome
partner applications, like
MugTug Darkroom, Clicker.
We showed you an amazing
demo by Sports Illustrated.
I hope that these serve to
get you excited about what
you can do with HTML5.
But, the exciting thing is
that we're not done yet.
We've still got a ways to go.
So, in the keynote, we talked
about three main areas.
We talked about
platform capabilities.
About letting you make your
web applications as rich,
contentful, and peachyful
as desktop applications.
And, we also talked about
solving the problems of
discovery and monetization.
In today's talk I'm going
to focus on the platform.
I want to share with you some
examples of the work that we've
done in Google Chrome in terms
of lessons learned, some
examples of UI decisions
that we had to make.
Sort of give you an
insight into how all
this development works.
So, my name is Ian Fette, I'm a
Product Manager on the Google
Chrome Team, and standing
besides me is Jeff Chang, also
a Product Manager on the
Google Chrome Team.
And, together I hope we are
going to provide you with a
good hour of entertainment.
So, what are we talking about.
I first want to go over
what is actually in HTML5.
There's a lot of
confusion there.
I want to give an update
on what has happened
since last year.
Who all was here at
Google I/O 2009?
Alright, I see a
lot of hands here.
We had a talk last
year on HTML5.
There was a lot of progress
made between last
year and this year.
So, I want to talk about some
of that, some lessons learned,
some new APIs we've added since
then, and I also want to tell
you about what's
coming up next.
Like all the others sessions
here at Google I/O 2010,
we're live waving.
The link is down
there on the bottom.
So, if you want to follow
along, if you want to ask any
questions, feel free, of
course, if you have questions
at the end, you're welcome
to come up to the mic and
ask the question there.
So, what the heck is an HTML5.
Even as of last year, at Google
I/O 2009, HTML5 had already
become a buzz word.
A lot of people used HTML5
to sort of mean the new
capabilities that have
been added since roughly
2008, give or take.
Is it technically correct?
No, there is a specification
called HTML5.
But, a lot of things have come
in to this specification, and
gone out of this specification
as time moves on.
So, when I say HTML5,
I'm going to use it in
the buzz word sense.
I'm going to use it to
mean the new capabilities
00:03:19,918 --> 00:03:19,658
that we're adding.
So, what are some of these
examples of changes that have
happened in the HTML5 spec.
HTML5 has actually shed
a lot of features.
When HTML5 started, it
was a spec being written
in what working group.
This was a consortium of
browsers and other interested
people online, trying to
come together to form a
specification for what would
become the next HTML standard.
And, it was one big
giant monolithic spec.
When a lot of its work moved
over to W3C, some things were
split out of the specification
into different specifications.
Into different
working groups even.
So, a lot of
the storage APIs, things like
the Web SQL Database, Web
Indexed Database, now called
Indexed Database API, is in
a different working group.
Geolocation, different
working group.
File API, different
Does this actually matter?
No, it doesn't.
A lot of this was done
for convenience.
A lot of it was, you know, when
you have one mailing list, one
giant working group, it's
really easy for things to get
lossed in the stream, it's
hard to follow what
you're interested.
So, a lot of this was split out
merely for convenience, not
because it's less important or
because we're not as
committed to it.
It's merely for the convenience
of those contributing to
and implementing the specs.
So, the fact that your favorite
API may not be in the HTML5
proper, and it's in a different
spec and a different working
group, it's not something that
you need to worry about.
Don't worry about it, we
still love it, we're
still implementing it.
But, given that there's so much
in HTML5, what are we actually
excited by, what are we
spending our time on, what are
we committing resources to
developing specifications
and implementing.
There's a few big areas that
we spent a lot of time on
over the past year even.
You can see some of
them on the screen.
One of them is offline.
We have been working on
offline, actually for more
years than I care to admit.
We started at Google with
Google Gears, which was our
attempt to give offline
capabilities to
web applications.
Google Gears gave web
applications the ability to run
offline, as well as the ability
to sort data on the
user's computer.
I'm very, very happy to see
that there's now a standard, an
actual W3C standard, around how
to do offline web applications,
and how to store data offline.
So, we spent a lot of time over
the past year implementing
those standards, and making
sure that people can use
offline web applications in
Google Chrome using
00:05:51,898 --> 00:05:51,66
web standards.
This is very important to us.
We didn't just say, you know,
oh, we have Gears, we have
offline capabilities, we're
done, we said there's a
standard, we're going to
support that we're going
to implement that.
We spent a lot time on media.
For those of you who were here
yesterday, and saw the keynote,
we announced we're
open sourcing VPA.
Why are we doing this.
Well, we believe that video is
an important part of the web,
and that there needs to be free
and open quota for video.
So, we have invested not to
just the making video supported
in Google Chrome, but making
sure there is a viable
option for an open video
standard on the web.
Networking, there's an API
called Web Sockets, that makes
it possible for you to have
bi-directional communication
from your client application,
your web application,
back up to a service.
So, I see some people out there
saying, you know, what's he
talking about, I can do this
already, it's called
00:06:43,82 --> 00:06:43,48
XmlHttpRequest.
And, yes, you do XHR, and you
can do hanging GETs, you have
communication back and forth
between your web application
and your server.
But, this has some
overhead, some downsides.
Let's say that you have a
chatty application that each
time a user presses a key, it
sends a message to the server,
Google Wave for instance, when
you send, when you're typing in
waves, all those
characteristics get sent to
server then sent down
to everyone else
following the wave.
If you think about how this
actually works, each time you
send a new request to the
server, you're not just sending
that letter, you're sending all
the cookies, all the headers.
So, we're very excited about a
new specification called Web
Sockets that lets you keep a
persistent connection opened
between the server and
the web application.
It's bi-directional, so either
the server or the client can
send data back and forth
with much less overhead.
We spent a lot of time on
that over the past year.
We're actually contributing
to that specification.
Things like CSS3, Paged Media,
giving you more control over
how your content is displayed.
Both on the screen and
on the printed page.
So, CSS3 gives you more
primitives for doing layout
that have been very difficult
in the past, and Paged Media
gives you primitives for how
you do that layout on
the printed page.
Things like controlling page
margins, headers, footers, all
sorts of -- there's like 16
margin boxes that you
can configure and put
random stuff in there.
You can also specify, you know,
what's supposed to happen if I
design my page for, my printed
page for A4, and the user
has letter or vice versa.
So again, this is something
we think is important.
If you look at Google
Documents, Google
Documents lets you print.
Right now, it generates a PDF.
You know, it works.
Is it optimal?
No.
So, this is an area that
we're spending time on.
And, platform integration.
You saw some of this in the
keynote, we'll talk a bit
more about this today.
We believe it's very important
that as desktop applications
can integrate with the
platform, we believe it's
important that web applications
can also integrate with the
host platform on which
they're running.
So, again, why are
we doing this.
We're doing this because we
want to provide a rich
experience for web
applications.
We want you to be able to give
your users the same sort of
features and experiences that
they can get from a desktop
application designed to
achieve a similar goal.
So, you know, we spent a lot of
time this year working on these
APIs, a lot of man hours
have gone into this.
We've learned a few lessons.
I want to share some of those
lessons with you, and give you
an insight into what it's like
building a browser,
building web standards,
building a new API.
One of the first lessons that
we learned, I said that we've
been working on offline
apps for years.
Believe me, we've learned a lot
of lessons with offline apps.
It's still not perfect,
we've got a ways to go,
but we're learning.
One of the key lessons that
we learned was around
discovery and rediscovery.
I don't know if any of you
used the offline version
of Gmail with Gears.
I see a few nods.
One of the problems is that
it's very hard for a user
to remember that they need
to type in a URL to reach
your offline application.
You know, when you're offline,
when you're in a plane, when
you board that flight back home
tonight, and you say gee, I
want to access my email, but I
don't have Wi-Fi, what do I do.
You know, you guys in the
audience are pretty tech savvy,
a number of you might figure
out that you can actually open
the browser and type in
https://mail.google.com, and oh
by the way, the origin
actually has to match.
So, if you just type
in gmail.com or
http://gmail.rule.com
it might not work.
Woops.
That's a problem.
And, that's something you
even remember you need
to type in a URL.
So, with Gears, we put a
shortcut on the desktop, and
that was a step forward.
But, it still didn't
solve the problem fully.
So, what we announced yesterday
was the Chrome Web Store.
Part of the Chrome Web Store is
about making your applications
discoverable, helping users
find that application you've
spent the time to write.
But, the problem is not just
finding the application the
first time, the problem is
second time, and the third
time, the rediscovery problem.
Knowing, how you get back to
that application, knowing how
you launch that application,
and actually feeling that that
application is available
to you, even when offline.
So, with the Web Store,
we're changing the new
tab page of Chrome.
To give web applications a
presence, not just in the form
of bookmarks, or an icon on the
tab -- like one of the
most visited pages.
But, an actual first class
treatment, as an installed
application in Google Chrome.
We're doing this, in part, so
users can rediscover that
application, and know
how to get back to it.
So, that when you are offline,
and you say gee, how do I
get to my email was
http://mail.google.com,
https:/mail.google.com,
gmail.com, gmail.de,
no that doesn't fit.
You can just click on the
icon, and it's there.
So, this has been one thing
that we've learned from
offline applications.
Another thing that we've
learned with the offline
applications, it usually
uses more APIs than
normal web pages.
It turns out if you're an
offline application, you
probably want to have some
offline data, but how much
offline data do you have.
If it's an e-mail app, 10
years ago maybe 5 megabytes
would have done it.
That's our current
default quota for
offline data.
Today, I bet most of you in
this room have more than
5 megabytes of e-mail.
When we designed a lot of
storage APIs, we sort of
scratched our head and
said gee, you know,
what we do for quota.
Well, we don't want any random
web application to be able to
fill up the disk,
that sounds bad.
So, let's put a limit on it.
Let's say 5 megabytes.
That seems sort of safe, like,
you know, I'm going to give you
5 megabytes, you can already
store cookies and cache,
so what the heck, 5 megs.
But, what do you do when you
want to have more than that.
We can prompt the user and say,
you know, Gmail.com wants to
use another 5 megabytes or
another 100 megabytes, do you
want to allow this, yes or no.
But, when do you prompt it.
If you think about it in terms
of how the spec is written
today, the logical answer would
be when you get somewhere
near to filling up the quota.
Lots of hand waving, you know,
the user agent should do
something intelligent.
Which, most people
interpret as prompting.
But, when are you going
to hit 5 megabytes.
You know, if you say, I want
to install Gmail offline,
and I want to use Gmail.
It would make sense to prompt
right then, but you're
not going to hit that 5
mega quota right then.
We're going to start
synchronizing some data, and
then maybe a minute later
you hit 5 megabytes.
So, you say, yes install Gmail,
yes let it work offline.
Then, a minute later you get
another info bar, yes let it
use more storage, and
then maybe it wants
to use notifications.
And, you say yes, let
it use notifications.
And, you end up answering
like 50 info bars.
It's like geez, I just wanted
to use this app, you know, when
I installed an app on my
Android phone, I didn't have to
like click yes on 50 different
info bars, why is this so hard.
So, another thing that the
Chrome Web Store is solving is
this problem of permission.
With the Chrome Web Store, when
you upload your application to
the Chrome Web Store, we let
you specify a set of
permissions that you want your
application to have.
So, now when a user goes to the
Chrome Web Store and says,
yes, I want to install this
application, we can handle all
those permissions up front.
And, we can say, yes, this app
should be allowed to access the
location, and access more than
5 megabytes of local storage,
and access notifications.
So, this has been a huge
lesson learned for months.
Is it standard yet.
Are all browsers
going to do this.
No, it's not standard yet.
We are trying to
see what works.
We're hopeful that we can find
a solution that works well.
And, assuming that we find a
solution that works well,
we're hopefully we can then
contribute that back in some
sort of a standard
friendly manner.
That's how we do things.
We don't try to specify
everything up front.
We try to innovate.
We try to make sure that we can
produce a good user experience,
and then contribute
that to a standard.
So, another lesson learned.
How many of you have
used Web SQL Database.
The local storage -- well
Web SQL Database now.
But, it basically gives you a
SQL database in the browser.
Anyone's used it?
Alright, I see a
number of hands.
One of the problems that this
spec faces, I personally love
it, I think it's a
very good idea.
A lot of people are familiar
with SQL, they like SQL.
But, one of the problems it
faces is that it's sort of
hard to specify how
this should work.
Is their a SQL standard.
Yes, there actually is,
something called SQL.
And, it has a
standard around it.
But, no implementation
just implement SQL.
Everyone implements SQL
plus, you know, whatever
else, you know.
How many of you used MySQL
on the server side?
I see a lot of MySQL people.
How many of you
used PostgreSQL?
I see some PostgreSQL people.
How many of you used SQLite?
I see some SQLite people.
How many of you used
MS SQL Server?
Some people.
How many of you used Oracle?
More hands.
So, it turns out if you try to
write a web application, you
have to care about that.
You have to care, am I running
a SQLite, am I running a MySQL,
am I running a PostgreSQL.
And, how many of you have ever
upgraded MySQL, and have your
application stopped working?
I see some hands there.
So, when we're designing a
specification, it turns out
it's not really sufficient to
just say, you know, issue a SQL
query and return a result.
We have to say what that means
in some sort of way that's
going to withstand
the test of time.
So, 10 years from now, maybe we
don't want to use SQLite 3
maybe we want to use SQLite 4.
And, maybe that has
a different syntax.
Maybe we don't want to
use SQLite at all.
Maybe we want to use
something else.
Maybe another browser, which
today once we implement this
specification doesn't want to
use SQLite, and wants to use an
alternative implementation.
What should they match.
Is there an actual standard
that specifies what the output
is with a given set of input.
Today, there's not.
So, we're looking
at alternatives.
One alternative that's being
proposed is to specify that
dialect of SQL that's
appropriate for this API.
I'm personally hopeful that'll
happen, because I do think that
there are a number of
developers who are comfortable
with the SQL model, and want to
use SQL on the client side just
as they use it on
the service side.
But, not everyone likes SQL,
and there are some concerns
about whether we can actually
specify the style up.
So, there's another
approach that we're
taking at the same time.
And, this is called the
index database API.
How many of you out there
are familiar with ISAM?
I see some hands.
OK, good.
We have some computer
science majors in the room.
What ISAM is, what this API
basically tries to achieve, is
to provide a table that is
indexed on a single field.
And, so you have an index that
is either a DOMString or a
long, so something that
we can easily index.
Then, you have an
associate value.
And, this value can be pretty
much anything, you know, it
can be an object, it can
be an array, whatever.
So, you then do lookups on
this table based on the key.
So, this key can be an author
name, it could be a book
ID, whatever you want.
And, then you pull up its
value, and that's it.
It's just matching on
the index, you have no
complex query language.
You can't do joins,
anything like that.
If you want to do any query
refinement to say, you know,
author is this, and is
hardcover, something like that.
You do that in JavaScript.
If you wanted to do any joins,
taking a table, joining the two
together, again you do
this in JavaScript.
This gives us a powerful
database, but also one that
is very easy to specify.
So, we're in the middle
of implementing this.
No browser actually has
an implementation yet,
we're working on it.
Hopeful that this turns into a
standard cross browser API
that's available everywhere,
its future proof.
Don't know if people actually
write on top of it directly.
My personal guess is that we
will see a lot of abstraction
layers written on top of this
API to make it easier to use.
So, any of you database
geeks out there feel
free to start writing.
What else have we learned.
Storage.
You know, databases are
great, but some people
want to store files.
If you think about an e-mail
application, you want a
way to store attachments.
If you think about an image
program, MugTug Darkroom that
you saw on the keynote, you
want a way to store images.
And, any of you database guys
out there know that if you try
to shove a large amount of
binary data in your database
and it's not designed for
that, bad things happen.
Turns out a lot of people try
to implement file systems
on top of databases.
So, we figured, well
what the heck.
People want file systems,
let's get them a file system.
So, now we're working on a file
system API, that gives you, the
web author, the ability to have
a sandbox per origin
file system.
So, what you get is
essentially, and this isn't
specified this way but in most
implementations I've seen, what
you get is a folder somewhere
buried deep in the users
profile directory, into
which you can create new
files and read files.
So, this is basically like
chrooted file system, that
you can do whatever the
heck you want with.
So, if you want to store
e-mail attachments,
great you can do it.
You want to store images,
You want to store all your
e-mail on something like a
Maildir format, you
can do that to.
And, the cool thing is that
we have exposed APIs for
FileReader and FileWriter,
that what you read and
write these files.
And, we're letting you create
blobs, that you can insert
anywhere that you would
normally insert an URL.
So, if you want to say image
source equals some file,
we're gonna make that work.
If you want to say href equals
some file, so that the user can
click on it, and download it or
open it, and whatever other
program they would use to open
that type of file, we're
going to make that work.
We're going to make it possible
for you to get a URN from these
files, that you can use
anywhere you would
use a web URL.
So, we're trying to make
a very flexible API.
This is also work in progress.
We're implementing it in
WebKit, so it should be
available in Chrome and Safari
hopefully this summer.
And, my personal
favorite, Geolocation.
You saw Geolocation in
Android quite a while ago.
Gears a while ago.
And, it sounded sort of simple
from a security perspective.
You say, you know, OK
here's a website.
The website wants to access
to user's location.
I'll ask the user, and say, you
know, should maps.google.com be
allowed to access your
location, yes or no.
It turns out, that when we
actually implemented this in
Chrome, and we sat down, and we
had a bunch of really privacy
minded people from our
Germany office as
well as some people here in the
Bay area, we started thinking
about some used cases where it
wasn't quite as clear cut.
You know, if I'm on
maps.google.com, and I say,
yes allow my location.
I understand that.
I [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
I'm saying OK, Google can
get my location for Google
maps, got it, great, next.
What happens now when I go to
another website, like Yelp.com
that has an embedded
Google maps gadget.
Should my location show up.
I don't know.
You know, I said yes,
let maps.google.com
access my location.
And, technically there's
JavaScript from maps.google.com
that's trying to
access my location.
So, you could argue that sure,
let's give the location
up, that sounds great.
But, from a users perspective,
what's actually happening.
I'm not on maps.google.com,
I'm at yelp.com, or some
other site, and someone
wants my location.
It's not really what I expect,
that I see my location
being given out.
So, what we did is
something different.
And, I'll show you.
So, here I am in Google Chrome,
this is actually Chromium a
nightly build, and I go
to maps.google.com.
I click to show my
location button.
And, I see this little info
bar saying, you know,
maps.google.com wants to
track your location.
I say allow.
And, now I see here I am,
I'm a up in San Francisco
at Moscone West.
00:23:41,56 --> 00:23:41
Great.
I see this little indicator
up here saying this page
is tracking your location.
I understand what's going on.
I'm comfortable with this.
It's something I understand.
Now, let's say that I go to
another webpage, which maybe
it's not quite as reputable.
You know, its this
IanFette.com site.
Who knows what that
guy is doing.
He's iFraming Google maps.
Oh my God.
Is my location going to show
up if I click this button.
And, the answer
right now is no.
It's not going to show up,
because what we did is we tied
the permission not just to the
origin of the script requesting
the location, but also the
origin of the top
level document.
So, here I am on IanFette.com,
I'm not getting access.
It's telling me that my
location is being requested.
So, I actually trust Ian
Fette, it's me, so I'm
going to allow it.
And, here I am at Moscone West.
So, what actually gets
saved from that.
If I click this little
indicator in the Omnibox,
I see that, you know,
that maps.google.com is
tracking my location.
If I hit manage location
settings, I can see, you know,
I'm always asked whether a site
should be able to
see my location.
If I click exceptions,
I can see the rules
that I've specified.
Here you see that
maps.google.com can get my
location, and maps.google.com,
when embedded on Ianfette.com,
can get my location.
But, maps.google.com on
Ianfette.org, for instance,
would not be able to
access my location.
So, this was an example of
an API that, you know, we
have implemented twice.
We thought was pretty simple,
but turned out to actually have
some pretty tricky UI problems.
So, when people say, you know,
it's easy to add another API,
it's easy to provide this
functionality, just
ask the user.
It turns out that asking the
user is not always easy to do.
So, when we were here at I/O
2009 last year, we were talking
about a lot of these APIs.
We were talking about
storage, about geolocation.
What have we actually done over
the past year, what are the
new work areas that we
started on this year.
One of the really cool ones,
and actually it might not sound
that cool, but it is, I promise
you, is shared state
between pages.
I talked earlier about
the file system API.
If any of you have written
native code, you know that when
dealing with files, you have to
worry about race conditions.
You have to worry about 2
threads accessing the same file
at once, and both trying to
make modifications
to that file.
Bad things can happen if you
don't worry about concurrency.
It turns out that with the File
API, the FileSystem API that
we're writing, same
thing can happen.
You can have race conditions.
You can have
concurrency issues.
And, HTML and JavaScript don't
really provide you with great
mechanisms for handling
things like locking.
So, what do you do.
There's an API called
SharedWorkers that lets you
effectively have multiple
pages, multiple tabs, multiple
frames, whatever, in the same
origin communicating with
each other via a post
message interface.
And, one of the cool
applications of this is that
you can use a SharedWorker
to serialize your
FileSystem access.
So, you could have a
SharedWorker do all the access
to the FileSystem, and you
could have all your other
worker threads in the main
thread just send requests to
the SharedWorker saying, you
know, please edit this file
in the following way.
And, the SharedWorker can take
care of ensuring all of those
are done in a safe manner.
So, SharedWorkers are great.
We love them.
But, they do have
some downsides.
One of the downsides is
that there's no single
scripting context.
So, you can't just take a huge
part of the dom, and hand it
off to a SharedWorker, and
hand that off to another
worker or another window.
It doesn't work.
It's the only things that
you can serialize, passed
in via post-message.
So, what do we do.
It turns out that this is
actually a useful thing to do.
One of things we're working on
in Gmail is making it possible
for you to open up a chat
window, or a composed window or
any other tear off window,
and have that be fast.
But, also have that window
survive if you close
the main window.
So, we want to have a
shared scripting context.
So, we're working on something
that we call Share iFrame, that
gives us a shared scripting
context with which we can pass
around in a part of the dom.
So, that we can build up
that composed window
even before you open it.
And, then just
hand off the dom.
We can make that window survive
even after the main window is
closed, by keeping all the
state in what we call
the magic iFrame.
This is a new approach.
It's not yet standard.
Again, it's just us trying to
think how do we innovate, how
do we do something new that
addresses real use cases.
And, if it turns out that
developers like it, we
will work on making sure
that it's available in all
browsers and standards.
At this point, I want
to turn over to my
colleague Jeff Chang.
He's going to talk to you a
little bit about some work
we've done around files,
dragging files and even more.
JEFF CHANG: Thanks Ian.
So, hopefully by now, you all
recognize that we want to make
web applications as powerful
as, if not more powerful
than, desktop applications.
And, one of the areas in
which we're doing that is
dragging and dropping.
Dragging and dropping not only
files from the desktop or the
files that's gone into the
browser, but vice versa.
And, obviously it's a very
simple and intuitive way to
kind of interact with files,
so that's why it's important.
There are a few different
examples here.
So, let me just walk
through each of them.
So, one of them is drag-in,
dragging in from the desktop
or any folder in the file
system into the browser.
One thing you can do here is
you can listen to the drop
event, obtain the file object.
and send it via XML HTTP
request to the server.
This makes sense if you have
a feature where you want to
upload a file to the server.
And, as you saw during the
keynote, and there's a screen
shot there, but I'll go
ahead and show you now.
This can be used in Gmail
to upload files in emails.
So, say I have an email here,
and I have a file on the
desktop that I want to attach.
So, let me go ahead
and put the message.
And, if I have the
file here, all I have to
do you is take it, drag
it over to message.
It tells me I
can drop the file here
as an attachment.
Let go, and the file gets
uploaded to the server.
Very intuitive, very
simple it just works.
Let me show you
another thing too.
This is also another feature we
recently launched in Gmail.
You can actually drag the
image into, such as inline
attachment, directly within
the message text itself.
So as long as my cursors are
there and I drag it and drop it
in this section instead, and
boom I get the nice little
kitten inside the
message itself.
That's very cool.
It just works.
So, there's other instances too
when you want to drag a file
in, but you might not
necessarily want to send
it up to the server.
Maybe the point of it is
that you want to just drag
the file in and start
interacting with it.
If you saw the keynote, there
was the application we showed
off MugThug Darkroom that
Travis Prichard showed.
And, in this case it's a
photo editing application.
Well, let's say I have the
skin, and I actually want to
do some photo effects on the
kitten, I can simply drag it
over here and using the file
reader interface,
in the file API.
I can now start interacting
with the file directly
on my local machine.
And, so I can apply the
filters, and change the
colors and what not.
And, in this whole time,
the file has stayed
on my local machine.
So, it doesn't need to be
sent up to the server.
And, in fact, this
works offline as well.
So, that's dragging in.
There's also dragging out.
That's from the browser.
So dragging out involves
dragging from the
browser to the desktop.
And, in this case, you actually
use the download URL format in
data transfer object, which
contains file type, the name of
the file, and the URL from
which to download the file.
So, let me show you a sneak
peak of a feature that we
are building in Gmail that
takes advantage of this.
This feature is basically you
have an email, and you have
a file attachment here.
And, you want to save it
somewhere in your computer.
I could have just click the
download link here, and I know
that's going to put it into the
default directory that Chrome
downloads to, whatever
that's set to.
But, this isn't my computer,
I don't actually know where
exactly that would download to.
I don't want to hunt
around for the file.
I just know I want to save the
file right here on the desktop.
So, what I'll do
is hover over it.
It prompts me click
or view to save.
Drag, drop right here.
And, bam, it downloads
it to my desktop.
So, again, very simple, very
intuitive, and a great way
to interact with files.
Another cool feature
is Notifications.
Hopefully you saw this
during the keynote as well.
I think the use case
here is pretty clear.
You want to let the application
notify the user in an
unobtrusive manner.
And, this can be a
variety of situations.
This could be, let's say you
have a calendar event that's
coming up that's really
important, you don't
want to miss that.
Let's say you have an email
that's coming into your
inbox, you want to be
notified about that.
You have Tweet coming in,
you want to see those.
Or, in this case, let's
say somebody sends
you a Google Chat.
Then bam.
You get a notification.
So, in terms of the actual way
this is implemented, the
developer, the app developer,
can provide the content
as HTML or plain text.
This feature does
have to be opt in.
The user does have to
permission it, it does have
to be assigned on an origin
basis for notifications.
And, in Chrome we do that in a
similar way to, what Ian showed
with geolocation, you get a
little info bar that says,
would you like to let this
domain show you notifications.
So, there's currently
two specs in progress.
Ones on the W3C website, and
ones on Chromium.org website.
But, the plan is to deprecate
the Chromium specific
one in favor of the
standards track one.
And, I believe the W3C one is
currently in editor's draft.
So, that's notifications.
So, I'm going to go ahead
and pass it back to Ian
now, who's going to
talk about some more
stuff on the Horizon.
00:33:51,5 --> 00:33:51,44
IAN FETTE: Thanks Jeff.
So, what's over the Horizon.
We've showed you
what we've done.
We've showed you some things
that we've been working
on over the past year.
What's coming next.
It turns out there's a lot
of new capabilities coming.
If you look at a lot of the
demos from Android this
morning, you'll see that
people used voice.
Voice turns out to be a very
natural interaction mechanism.
People want to speak
their input for certain
types of queries.
If you think about it, I drove
here in a Toyota Prius, I
could hit a button and say,
you know, Moscone West.
I could drive up here, I have
that, you know, pre-programmed,
it gets recognized.
I can control my
car with my voice.
And, my car can
speak back to me.
There's voice recognition,
and there's text speech.
So, we figured, why not build
that into the browser.
So, we're going to do it.
How do we do it though.
We don't want to just give you
a giant wave file and say,
here you go figure out
what the user said.
That wound't actually
be that useful.
So, what we're doing is we're
adding a new input tag.
We're calling it input
type equals speech.
And, our vision for this is
that it will like input
type equals text.
It probably will produce
a little text area.
But, also have a little
microphone button, that the
user can click on to say, yes,
I actually want to speak now,
and I want you to recognize
what I'm speaking.
And, when the user does
this, we will recognize
the users speech.
We'll take that audio send it
up to a server for processing,
although it could also be
done locally depending on
implementation, and make that
available to the website.
So, whatever the user speaks
will be transcribed, and put
into the value of the tag.
We'll also give you even
more control though.
Because, it turns out that's
not quite sufficient.
For any of you who have dealt
with speech processing in
the past, you know that in
specialized areas, you might
want to restrict the grammar.
So, if you're calling up Delta
and they're asking you is this
a domestic flight or an
international flight.
Turns out, they only want
to know if it's domestic
or international.
They don't want to know
if you want pizza.
So, if you provide a grammar,
you can make it possible to
have even better accuracy
and recognition.
So, we're going to support
providing a grammar
for that input tag.
We'll also give you events,
like change events and stock
events, so that you can process
the data sequentially.
So, as the user is speaking and
we recognize another word,
we'll give you an event, so
that you can act on that.
Or, if you only care about it
at the end, we'll give you
an event for that too.
So, that's how you can
get data in from voice.
How do you get data out.
How do you speak results back.
How do you say, you know,
turn left in 300 meters.
Oops you went too far, make a
legal u-turn when possible.
We're going to provide an
API called text to speech.
You know, it makes sense, TTS.
This will be another tag where
you provide a value, and that
value is whatever gets
spoken to the user.
But, we're going to make it
just like audio tag, so it will
inherit from the audio tags.
So, that you'll have all same
controls, that you would
have from the audio tag.
You can play.
You can pause.
You can stop.
You can script it in JavaScript
in the exact same way that you
would script an audio
tag or a video tag.
So, we're hopeful that these
two APIs together will enable a
whole new class of application
on both mobile browsers as
well as desktop browsers.
Because, if you look at a
lot of netbooks being
sold today, they all have
microphones in them.
So, why not let the
websites access them.
It turns out that many cameras,
netbooks, and even laptops
have another device.
So, we're not just going
to give you access
to speech input.
We're not just going
to do transcription.
We also realize that if you
really want to access that
microphone, and do everything
you can with it, you might
want to record the sound.
You might want to record
yourself singing a
new Lady Gaga song.
So, you can put that
up on YouTube.
Or, you might just want to,
for whatever reason, take
that, process it as
a wave, and do your
own processing.
So, we're going to give you
access to the microphone in
terms of just being able
to get a single blob up.
The other API that we want to
expose is access to the webcam.
It turns out that that's the
other device that many laptops,
netbooks, and cameras,
excuse me cell phones, are
shipping with is a camera.
So, how do we give
you access to that.
Similar to the microphone, we
want to provide two methods.
We want to provide a way for
you to get a Blob, a still
picture that you can use
locally, upload to the
server, whatever you want.
And, we also want to be
able to give you a stream.
So, if you want to have a video
chat application, for instance,
we want to enable that.
So, we want to give you access
to a stream of video as well.
This is not something that
we have working yet.
It's something
that's in progress.
You saw a preview of this in
the keynote, but there's a lot
more to come in this area.
So, audio is cool.
I love cars talking to me.
I love hearing a recorded
sound played back to me.
But, how many gamers
do I have out here?
Okay, good.
I see some hands.
I love games.
It turns out, that if you're
playing a first-person shooter,
and you've got a 5.1 sound
system, you want to know who's
shooting at you and from where.
You want positional audio.
You want that sound to be able
to come not just from the right
or from the left, but from in
front of you, from behind
you, from at an angle.
You want things like reverb.
So, we are going to give you
access to a fully featured
positional audio API that will
give you all these controls.
It will give you things like
control over directionality.
It will give you volume, send
configuration, gain,
inner/outer cone, distance
attenuation, pitch, occlusion,
obstruction, reverb.
All of these things
will be supported.
And, it'll be supported in a
way that's simple for you, so
you don't have to implement
a full physics engine in
JavaScript just to try to do
positional audio on your own.
So, this will also make it
possible to develop richer
games in the browser.
But, richer games need more
than just great audio It turns
out they need great video.
And, Canvas and the video
tag alone are not enough.
So, we're working on
supporting 3D in the browser.
There's a new specification
being developed called WebGL
that exposes OpenGL via
JavaScript findings.
And, with this, you can
create immersive 3D scenes.
So, you can access the full
power of the GPU that's on that
desktop computer, that's on
that laptop computer, that may
even be on that mobile phone.
So, this 3D video, together
with positional audio, will
also enable a new class
of applications.
WebGL was actually pioneered
a while ago by Firefox, and
Google also did work in this
area with up with O3D.
There's some differences
between WebGL and the O3D
work that we did earlier.
Namely, with O3D, you
build up a scene.
And, that scene is retained, so
it's called retained mode API.
And, you can make
changes to the scene.
You can say, you know, take
the torch and make it
lean left, lean right.
But, you don't redraw
the scene each time.
With WebGL, it's a director
and media mode API.
So, each time you issue queries
saying draw this vertex here,
this vertex there, you know.
You basically draw
it each time.
So, there is a difference, but
we're doing work for those
of you who invested an O3D.
We're doing work to provide
a compatibility layer
for O3D on top of WebGL.
So, we're excited by WebGL.
I want to show you a quick
demo of what you can do.
I was hoping to be able to
show you the beach demo,
I can't show you that.
But, one of the cool things
that you can do, if you look at
the source code for this, which
I'm not going to do, but this
is actually very, very small
in terms of source code.
It's a pretty simple
application.
But, I can do all sorts of
things like, you know, create
3D effects, little puffs,
little trails of fire
going around in a circle.
And, it's all very possible.
It works very well.
And, this actually works both
in Google Chrome with a
command line flag, as well
as with Mozilla Firefox.
So, this is already getting
great reception, great
adoption, and I really do
believe that this is going
to enable a new class
of applications.
A new set of games.
Really help people understand
that the browser is a great
place to develop that
application that you
want to develop.
So, with that, I want to
turn it over for Q&A.
I hope that I have given you a
bit of insight into how browser
development works, how the
development of standards works,
and inspired you in
terms of HTML5.
That's my hope.
Please feel free.
There are microphones here in
the aisles, if you have any
questions, come on up, I'm
happy to answer them.
Thanks [APPLAUSE].
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for the talk.
Can you explain the
behavior, how the grammar
00:43:10,258 --> 00:43:10,078
attribute will work?
Is there going to be a limit
on the length, or how that
attribute would work?
IAN FETTE: So, there's an
existing specification that
I believe actually is
being worked in W3C for
grammars of languages.
We're hoping to leverage that
existing specification.
I have to apologize, I don't
actually remember the name
off the top of my head.
AUDIENCE: What is it again?
IAN FETTE: SSML.
So, if you the search for that,
you should be able to find
more details in voice XML.
Sorry, I don't actually
remember off the top of my
head, you'll have to search on
that, but we're hoping to make
it as full featured
as possible.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm very excited about
exposing tensors on mobile
devices through HTML5.
Do you have plans to expose
more, like the Accelerometer
and other things like that?
IAN FETTE: Yes, so the Android
Web Browser Team is very
interested in figuring out how
we expose all capabilities of
the platform, not just the
microphone and the camera, but
things like the accelerometer,
the magnetometer for direction.
So, we're working on
exposing all those.
Of course, as we do that, we'll
also work with standards bodies
to make sure that there is a
standard around this, and it
works not just on Android
devices, but on any mobile
device that chooses to
implement the standard.
We want to make that
work everywhere.
JEFF CHANG: I believe they
demonstrated the, at least the
compass in Android and in the
browser during the keynote.
They were showing it,
turning it around.
IAN FETTE: Yes.
So, we're definitely
working on it.
JEFF CHANG: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Speaking of new input
devices, what about pressure
sensitivity and sub-pixel
positioning for graphics?
IAN FETTE: Pressure sensitivity
and sub-pixel positioning.
I can't say it's honestly at
the top my priority list.
I'm happy to add it onto
the list, and try figure
out how to do it.
But, right now, I think
we're at the point where
we have so much going on.
We're still working on a lot of
the primitives, like the how
you store data, how you make an
offline application accessible,
how you draw basic data
with Canvas and WebGL.
So, yes I agree that, you
know, it is a valid use case
and something we should
figure out how to do.
But, it's not something we're
actively working on just yet.
I apologize.
Although someone at the
W3C is, Doug tells me.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: At the risk of
sounding greedy will you
localize translate input
speech and text to speech?
IAN FETTE: So, will we localize
-- you're basically asking
would we do translation of the
text to speech in voice input.
Sounds like fun challenge.
I'm sure someone at Google
would love to do it.
I can't tell you that we're
actually doing it yet,
but it sounds fun.
So, we'll consider it.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: One thing I've
noticed is that when the
browser requires a permission
dialog, usually it seems to be
at the point that JavaScript
requests for something.
So, is there like a way maybe
through a meta tag or something
that you can say this site is
going to ask for location for
disk space, etc. etc. before it
gets to that point in the code?
IAN FETTE: So, right now
there's not a declarative
model to ask for a lot of
permissions in advance.
It's one of the things that
we're trying to figure out
with the Web Store, is
how do I provide a
good declarative model.
And, our hope is that if we get
that right, and developers
respond positively saying, you
know, yes, this is a good
model, this is the capability
that we actually want
that works for us.
That, we can turn it into a
standard that's usable not just
for applications packaged up in
the Web Store, but on any
application regardless of
whether it's in the Web Store
or whether it's a URL
I just browsed to.
So, we want to make it possible
for all web pages to declare
the permissions that
they intend to use.
So, it's something
we want to do.
We're not there yet, but
we're working on it.
JEFF CHANG: And, one thing to
add to that which Eric Kay
showed at the Web Store session
earlier today was, we
definitely want to kind
of simplify that user
experience for people.
Because, let's say you have a
crazy off the map that uses the
camera and the microphone, the
notification, the geolocation,
and all this stuff.
You know, we don't want to just
show the user info bar, info
bar, info bar and
like 5, 6 things.
00:47:22,36 --> 00:47:22,34
Do you want to do this.
Do you want to let it do this.
And, they'll be like, yeah, I
guess, I guess, I guess, maybe.
And, so the idea behind the Web
Store, which Eric was showing
was at the time of installation
of the application, when you're
actually creating that shortcut
on your new tab page, then you
can see this application is
using all these things.
And, that itself is hard coded
into the manifest that the
application developer
has provided.
And, so at that point it has
been cleared, and you never
have t kind of inundate the
user with a bunch of info bars.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I had a couple of
other questions.
Most voice systems are actually
optimized to understand
natural speech.
So, the way I'm speaking now.
But I believe a lot of people
when they speak to -- a
computer speaks to them, hello
how are you, and then they want
to speak back clear enunciated
and then the system messes up.
So, how do you handle that?
Have you considered that all?
IAN FETTE: So, yes and no.
Yes, you definitely do need to
take that into account when
designing the voice
recognition.
It's sort of orthogonal to
the actual standard that
goes in the browser.
But, Yes, it's something we're
of that certain people do tend
to speak differently when
speaking to a voice
recognition systems.
However, there are a number
of people who do not speak
clearly, and enunciate clearly
when speaking to a computer.
So, you do have to handle both.
It is something that our team
is, the Voice Team at Google
is definitely aware of.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Then one other thing was --
IAN FETTE: Last question.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah, please
IAN FETTE: OK.
AUDIENCE: So, there's a lot
of stuff going on with the
browser, but in terms of HTML
itself is, well kind of ugly.
And, what about having
some sort of system that
could searches through
JSON or something.
I mean as we're moving
a web applications.
Being able to somehow
understand content when
it's not just HTML.
IAN FETTE: You know something,
there's a number of proposals
for markup for meta data.
You know, it's a lot of people
for a lot of years have said,
you know, if we have all this
meta data about data, we can do
a better job of searching it.
To some extent that's true, but
to another extent if you look
at Google as search engine, it
actually does a remarkable just
inferring from untagged data.
So, if I'm ready to throw in
the towel on HTML just yet.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
IAN FETTE: Yes?
AUDIENCE: If you track a folder
or multiple files, how's that
handled, and follow
up questions is --
IAN FETTE: Yeah.
So, you get a file list that
you can then enumerate it and
get individual files
from the file list.
AUDIENCE: So, folders you
can have, and you can get
everything, recursive
folders, everything in --
JEFF CHANG: So, there is a
directory upload proposal
that's being worked on by John
Gregg, and I believe it's
making the rounds on the Web
WG mailing list right now.
In order to be able to have an
input type equals directory or
whatever, and actually have the
recursive things of
a hold directory.
So, it's not in the specs
yet, but something already
being actively discussed.
IAN FETTE: Multiple files, yes.
Directory with multiple
files in the works.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And a follow up if you have a
large file like a gigabyte
video, is there any resume
upload or anything like that?
IAN FETTE: Is
there any what?
00:50:43,076 --> 00:50:42,94
Sorry.
AUDIENCE:
Resume upload.
JEFF CHANG: Sorry, I think
blob.slice does that, right?
IAN FETTE: So, with the File
API, you can get access
to the file locally.
And, you can slice it to
get access to parts of the
file and send those up.
We are working on ways to
make it more convenient
to do resumption.
I'm not entirely clear right
now how that would look.
But, it is technically
possible, right now
if not convenient.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: With the Chrome App
Store, when you download the
information to one computer, is
their any intent or something
built in already for being able
to use that application on a
different computer, with a
different installation
of Chrome?
JEFF CHANG: So, I mean, I think
in general with Chrome, we've
worked that point trying to
make the web experience sync
across all of your
installations.
And, so that you can take your
web experience with you as you
travel, different computers,
and different installations.
As you know, we already have
things like bookmarks, and
themes and preferences.
And, so we certainly would
envision the Web Store in your
installed applications to
fit into that picture.
AUDIENCE: So, from what I've
seen, your voice recognition
software is pretty
much awesome.
But, what's the expected
quality for text to speech.
Is it going to sound
really blocky all the time?
And, what have you guys looking
into to kind of make that
more fluid so it sounds less
like a robot and more like
something's talking to me.
IAN FETTE: So, text to speech
has actually come quite a ways
since, I think the first time I
used it was Microsoft Agent
back when I was in
middle school.
It's come long ways.
I can't into any details about
what we're specifically
doing to make it better.
And, other implementations,
other browsers might have
different ideas for how they
implement it, be that
locally in the client,
around the server.
I think our main focus
is on making the
interaction possible.
And, once we have that base
level, we'll see what needs are
not met, you know, someone
really wants to specify.
You know, make this sound like
Governor Schwarzenegger and
here's some data that
describes his voice.
You know, we'll try to figure
out how to make that possible.
But, I think in v1, we're
really just hoping to found the
basic use cases of how to take
this text and convert it --
AUDIENCE: So, in the basic use
case then, is it going to sound
really blocky in the first run?
IAN FETTE: I don't think it's
going to sound really blocky.
I mean I don't think it's going
to sound like a 1990s robot.
It might not as
configurable as you like.
But, I'm pretty sure
that we'll be able to
deliver a high quality.
JEFF CHANG: It will sound
like a 2010 robot.
IAN FETTE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE
AUDIENCE: All right, thanks.
IAN FETTE: I think we saw
some of that last night.
Yes, next question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Regarding web sockets, is there
any kind of support in Android?
IAN FETTE: Is there any web
socket support in Android?
So, a lot of the work that
we did for web sockets
is contributing
upstream in WebKit.
Android pulls WebKit.
I don't actually remember what
revision they're pulling
in [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
or whether that includes web
socket supports that they've
done all the necessary
plumbing for that.
So, the honest answer is
I'm not entirely sure.
I would love to see them
support it, but I can't
speak for that team.
I'm sorry.
Doug?
DOUG: Hey, so I just wanted
to -- there were a lot of
questions -- you did some stuff
on audio and there were a lot
of questions about audio.
I just want to mention that
W3C has a new sort of
community audio group.
So, we're collecting used case
in requirements for everything
from audio synthesis, audio
reading and writing the audio
stream to text the speech,
to -- the whole range.
It's a community thing, so
everybody wants to get involved
in discussions about that.
Sorry to abuse the mic.
IAN FETTE: Oh, it's fine.
And, I should actually say
something really quick.
You know, in terms of standards
development, there's a lot
going on, there's a
lot of standards.
And, we don't always know
what you want, or whether
these standards actually
match what you want.
So, I encourage all of you
to actually get involved.
Go to whatwg.org.
00:54:49,038 --> 00:54:49,018
Go to w3.org.
Find these mailing lists,
they're easy to find.
There's Public Web Ask
at w3.org, there's
What WG at whatwg.org.
Get involve, follow them.
If there is an API that you
actually care about, or whether
it's address a use case you
care about, make sure that we
hear your feedback, make sure
we know whether this API
actually works for you or not.
Because, if you don't give us
this feedback now, it's so
much harder to go back
and change it later.
Which is not to say we can't do
it, but getting that feedback
now is super valuable.
So, please do get involved
in things like the W3C.
DOUG: I think if you Google
for W3C audio incubator,
that will find you.
00:55:31,198 --> 00:55:31,038
IAN FETTE: Thanks Doug.
I just heard Google.
Next.
AUDIENCE: Speaking of APIs if
you want, how would you go
about -- something I really
want is to have access within
the browser to the certificate
store, to encryption and
decryption and signing.
The stuff that every browser
does for SSL, but I want to
give it to my application.
And, where would I even start
the plant the seed for that.
IAN FETTE: So, where you start
is by going to -- assuming
that there is no
spec that already handles it or
even if there it is, go to
bugs.chromium.org and file a
feature request and say this is
the kind of application
that I want to build.
This is the kind of use
case I want to support.
How are you going
to do it for me.
And, believe it or not, even
though we do have tens of
thousands of blogs open on that
site, we do read them and
we will actually take that.
Because, that's how we know
that people this capability.
And, that's how we know
the need to look at it.
It turns out that encryption
is something we're actually
00:56:27,54 --> 00:56:27,42
looking at already.
If you look at a lot of banks
in East Asia, particularly
China and South Korea, all of
them are using active x
controls to do signatures
on transactions.
AUDIENCE: Us too.
IAN FETTE: So, it's a very
legitimate use case.
There are a lot of
existing uses of that.
We nee to figure out a
way to support that
with web standards.
So, it's something that
I'm very keen to do.
Unfortunately, I don't have
a date for you on that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Is Google thinking
about standardizing like parts
of the Web Store experience,
like app launching, you
know, the app cache or
saving you web apps?
IAN FETTE: So, I think we want
to figure out what makes sense
to standardized, and
standardized that.
One of the examples is like
the declared or permissions.
We want to figure out how
to standarized that.
I don't think we'll
standardize the entire thing.
I mean some of it is
from proprietary.
But, the parts that makes
sense with our cross browser.
Yes, obviously we're opened
to standardizing that.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: For Chrome extensions
it's easy to do cross
domain requests.
I'm just wondering if there's a
way that Google's looking at
making that kind of like a
permission that could be added,
so that somebody can do that in
non-extensions, rather than
using like JSONP or something?
IAN FETTE: So, you can use
things like cores and UMP to
specify what -- Geez, I'm
blanking on the actual API.
It should be possible.
You're not ever going to be
able for a web page, you
know, randomly script
another web page.
But, if that other web page ops
in, it is possible to do that.
I believe there's cross origin
XHR already shipping in Chrome.
Come up to me after,
and I will answer your
question more fully.
I apologize.
You caught me on top
of my head here.
AUDIENCE: No problem.
Thanks.
IAN FETTE: So, I see that
my clock in the back is
actually flashing red.
So, I think that means
I'm out of time.
Thank you all so
much for coming.
I really appreciate it Jeff and
I will hang out for a few
minutes if you have
more questions.